اعلنا البنتاغون عن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
جديده الى اوكرانيا تقدر بنحو 800 مليون
دولار بين هذا خائر عنقوديه وقال وكيل
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه كولين كال ان
الحزمه تشمل مزيدا من الذخائر والاسلحه
والمعدات التي تحتاج اليها كياث في حربها
ضد روسيا
تواصل الولايات المتحده دعمها المستمر
لاوكرانيا باعلانها اليوم عن حزمه مساعدات
عسكريه جديده لتزويد قواتها بمزيد من
الذخائر والاسلحه والمعدات التي تحتاجها
للدفاع عن بلادها في وجه العدوان الروسي
حزمه المساعدات هذه تضم ذخائر اضافيه
لنظام باتريوت للدفاع الجوي وذخائر هايمرز
ومركبات برادلي وناقلات مدرعه وذخائر جويه
دقيقه
واضاف وكيل وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه كولين
كال عن كييف قدمت لواشنطن ضمانات باستخدام
الذخائر العنقوديه بشكل مسؤول واضاف
كولينكال ان بلاده ستضمن حصول اوكرانيا
على ما يكفي من تلك الذخائر لعده اشهر
الحكومه الاوكرانيه قدمت لنا ضمانات
مكتوبه لاستخدام الذخائر العنقوديه بشكل
مسؤول وتعهدت بعدم استخدامها في مناطق
مقتظه بالمدنيين وتوثيق مكان استخدامها ما
يسهل جهود نزع الالغام لاحقا وعبر تزويد
اوكرانيا بالذخائر العنقوديه سنضمن ان
يكون لدى الجيش الاوكراني ما يكفي من
الذخائر المدفعيه لعده اشهر